welcome to now you see it this video of
a train was first screened to a group of
people in France in January of 1896
legend has it that the viewers of the
film were so overwhelmed by what looked
like a train coming right at them that
many hid under their seats or ran to the
back of the room in fear of getting hit
the truth of this story is debated but
what's certain is that seeing a video
for the first time of a train coming
towards you would probably leave you
pretty shocked and amazed so the
question is even more than a century
later can we be just as moved by film or
are we desensitized because we know that
things on-screen aren't actually
happening to us
I want to explore the war film because
war films have such great potential to
shock and amaze us through their sheer
scope and powerful subject matter how
can films portray war and what
techniques do filmmakers used to picked
war and the soldiers that fight them can
film portray war realistically let's
take a look at two types of war films
pro war and anti war French filmmaker
Francois Truffaut is often attributed
with saying there's no such thing as an
anti-war film while Steven Spielberg
said in an interview with Newsweek
magazine of course every movie good or
bad is an anti-war movie so who's right
I want to argue that while neither of
these statements is correct they do give
insight into the nature of film but
before arguing if a film is pro or anti
war we have to define Pro and anti war a
definition like anti war portrays war in
a bad light and pro war portrays war in
a good light is somewhat of an
oversimplification a lot of war films
show a combination of positive and
negative aspects of war they were
expendable for example shows Japanese
airplanes blowing up a US PT boat and
killing a soldier look at this shot of
John Wayne collapsing at the side of the
boat weighed down by his combat boots
the camera following him to the ground
this scene reflects war is cruel
dangerous and deadly but if we look at
the movie as a whole it's definitely a
pro war propaganda film look at this
shot of General MacArthur commander of
the army he towers over the camera
speaks little and is treated by the
soldiers as a celebrity he's looked at
as a hero and savior for the United
States and this and along with lots of
pro war sentiment in the film shows that
they were expendable is much more pro
war than anti war
I think a better definition for a
pro-war film would be a film that shows
the benefits of war outweighing the
costs and an anti-war film shows the
cost of war outweighing the benefits a
modern example of a pro war film is
American sniper clint eastwood makes the
claim that the film is anti-war and it
definitely has a lot of aspects of an
anti-war film the film shows that war
isn't always black and white and can
cause serious emotional trauma but what
makes it pro war is that Chris Kyle
believes he did the right thing
I just protecting my guys they were
trying to kill our soldiers and I'm
willing to meet my Creator and as for
every shot that I took the film is pro
war because it conveys that despite all
the trauma of war war seems worth it in
their allusion and blessed with the gift
of aggression and the overpowering need
to protect the flock these men of the
rare breed lived to confront the wolf
they are the sheepdog the benefits of
war outweigh the cost and war is a
necessary evil against those who cause
terror it's with films like American
sniper where I think Spielberg is wrong
in his statement about war films war
films normally don't make out war is
something to look forward to but they
can certainly make war out as necessary
Pro war films use heroes and an idea of
the greater good to convey the message
that war is necessary and anti-war film
showcase the brutality and cruelty of
war to portray combat negatively to get
a look at how filmmakers use
cinematography to have an anti-war film
show the horrors and realities of combat
one has to look no further than the
d-day scene in Saving Private Ryan
the transition from the old man in the
opening scene to the beaches of Normandy
is done with a jarring smash cut we
don't fade in
we don't zoom in it's a fast and abrupt
transition it gives the effect of being
forced into the scene without adequate
preparation the shot of the endless rows
of anti landing barriers on the beach
looks eerily similar to the rows of
tombstones in the graveyard we just saw
in the earlier scene a foreshadowing of
what's to come we get several close-ups
of soldiers and they certainly aren't
the typical war heroes the first image
of our hero is his hand shaking a sign
of fear compare that to the grand
introduction of John Wayne on a squadron
of PT boats that are basically showing
off to the camera or even American
sniper we're Chris Kyle first gets shown
with this huge powerful sniper rifle the
omaha beach scene shows a war fought by
the terrified not by the heroic or
masculine the killing on the beach is
best described as pure chaos the camera
shake point of view shots and minimal
movement blur all worked together to
pull the viewer onto the battlefield
alongside the other soldiers with all
these effects this seemed definitely
conveys that the costs of war outweighed
the benefits a great way for a film to
portray war in a negative way is to make
war scenes as realistic as possible by
putting us in the real world we feel the
terror and get a sense that war may not
be worth all the turmoil it causes waltz
with bashir is another great example of
pulling us into the action and showing
how war can have such devastating
effects the movie is an animation war
film and the resulting effect is that
were removed from the reality in the
film because it's animated and doesn't
look realistic then in the last minute
or so the film quickly cuts to actual
footage of the aftermath of the
massacres in Lebanon the result is
heart-wrenching it jars us from the
spectacle of the animation into the
harshness of reality we see widows
crying dead bodies and it's also naddis
with no preparation for the transition
from cartoon to reality the effect is
extremely powerful and we realized that
what we were originally seeing only in
animated characters is in fact exactly
the reality of war and that reality is
horrific suffering if that's not an
anti-war film then I don't know what is
I do see where try food is coming from
when he says there's no such thing as an
anti-war film he's saying that film by
nature contains spectacle since we're
not actually on the battlefield and are
safe in our movie theater seats we don't
completely feel exactly like the
soldiers do because we're removed from
the reality this removal makes it
difficult to construct a film that truly
leaves people disgusted at war because
we're safe from it we can enjoy watching
the destruction of film in the theater
famous director Samuel fuller upon
watching the very anti-war
full-metal-jacket stated that it was
just another goddamn recruiting film
even when films try to criticize war
sometimes they can still give the effect
of making war glamorous cinema as an art
form is limited because no matter how
John in we are to the movie there's
always that barrier from reality a train
on screen doesn't frighten us like it
would in real life so maybe we are a
little desensitized by the screen
we aren't shocked like the viewers of
the train were back in 1896 some may say
that's a limitation to film but to
others it's a challenge it's a challenge
all filmmakers have to tackle they have
to surprise and astonished us even when
we're used to watching film and maybe
not every blockbuster these days can
blow you away but every once in a while
if you're lucky you get to see a film
that hits you like a freight train
thanks for watching